[Musica]
buonasera ho da fare una richiesta e
chiedere alle persone bionde della
platea della sala di alzare per favore
la mano no mi dimentico sempre che sono
cieco dalla nascita e con la mano non
funziona molto bene allora chiedo alle
persone
more al mio tre di dire sono moro 123
benissimo
stasera vi parlo della fiducia e pensate
che figata mi sono già fidato di voi
avreste potuto prendermi in giro è
invece non l'avete fatto di questo vi
ringrazio
avrebbe potuto nascondervi magari dietro
la sedia rifugiarvi invece avete
ripagato ripagato la mia fiducia è una
persona quando non vede si deve per
forza affidare degli altri
noi abbiamo come aspirazione aspiriamo
tutte le persone che non vedono
all'autonomia e alla capacità proprio di
essere autosufficienti di essere
autonomo anche le tecnologie di cui
abbiamo visto uno stralcio fino ad ora
ci aiutano ci sostengono e il problema
però è che prima o poi nell'arco della
giornata
nell'arco di un anno nell'arco di un
mese una persona che non vede deve
fidarsi delle persone per chi non vede
sfidarsi a una bella chiave di svolta
per stare bene per stare meglio partendo
dalle cose banali fidarsi di una persona
che ti consiglia come vestirti fidarti
di una persona che ti dice la scadenza
dell'hamburger che hai nel frigo fidare
di una persona che ti accompagna magari
per mano e ti fa ti spiega come una
strada come una situazione che stai
vivendo e questo è bello perché mi sono
reso conto che si fa molta fatica a
fidarsi delle persone è invece una cosa
che io personalmente devo fare sempre
sempre sempre sempre
quando sono in situazioni anche
tranquille con gli amici con miei
conoscenti con tutti sono portato
appunto a fidarmi diciamo che io per
professione mi fido ciecamente di tutte
le persone o di molte persone che
incontro però la fiducia non è solo
questo la fiducia mi ha consentito di
fare cose che altrimenti non farei
pensate provate a immaginarvi quando
andate magari chi di voi sia sulla neve
quando andate a sciare sulla neve e
siete a mina all'apice di una montagna
quindi vicini a una pista pronti per
partire ma non vedete nulla è lì bisogna
affidarsi veramente ciecamente di chi ci
guida e io penso che se non l'avessi se
non avessi imparato a farlo non potrei
far non potrà sciare
quindi la fiducia non è solo una cosa
che sono costretto a fare per la
quotidianità ma è anche uno strumento
che mi permette di veramente poter fare
cose alle quali non avrai accesso lo
stesso nello sci nautico
il salto quando io salto dal tram col
trampolino o una persona che mi
accompagna fino alla rampa a 55 60
chilometri orari e mi dice quando
saltare se questo non è fidarsi
ciecamente veramente sfido chiunque a
spiegarmi il concetto di fiducia
veramente profonda anche nella
arrampicata quando io ho provato
arrampicarmi già per chi vede quando uno
si arrampica hai una persona che ti
tiene la corda ti fa la sicura e quindi
ci si fida di altri per noi quando siamo
aggrappati a un muro a qualcosa abbiamo
in basso una persona che ci dice metti
la mano qui metti la mano li e quindi
anche lì veramente ci fidiamo di chi
abbiamo intorno
e allora ho pensato come mai spesso le
persone non si fidano siamo abituati
anche noi tutti i giorni a essere
costretti a dare fiducia si fa fatica a
dare fiducia alle persone perché magari
una persona dobbiamo delegare qualcosa o
far fare a qualcuno qualcosa al posto
nostro e si fa
tremendamente fatica nonostante dare
fiducia a un valore aggiunto per noi ma
è anche un qualcosa di potenziante per
gli altri
eppure noi ci fidiamo quotidianamente
quando perdiamo un taxi quando prendiamo
un pullman quando vediamo un aereo ci
fidiamo di persone che nemmeno
conosciamo e non riusciamo a fidarci o
facciamo molta più fatica a fidarci
magari di un collega un amico di un
parente e questo è straordinario anche
al supermercato andiamo a comprare un
alimento ci fidiamo di una serie di
persone chi lo ha portato lì chi lo ha
confezionato kg ha cucinato comunque chi
lo ha prodotto per noi ci stiamo finendo
di tutte queste persone e facciamo
fatica a fidarci di un altro non ha più
di un esterno che magari invece
conosciamo anche bene
eppure dare fiducia e potenziante per
chi la riceve pensiamo ad esempio ai
bambini un modo bellissimo per
responsabilizzare un bambino e per far
sì che magari smetta di fare i capricci
e diciamo così ci ascolti e si
responsabilizza e appunto è quello di
dargli fiducia bambino quando il
privilegio di avere la nostra fiducia la
difende la protegge con tutte le forze e
si prova con pur prova comportarsi
veramente e si concentra concentra tutti
i propri sforzi per evitare di deluderci
per evitare di disattendere la nostra
fiducia quindi la fiducia non è
solamente un qualcosa che aiuta noi
perché ci rende la vita più facile per
esempio a me lo fa tutti i giorni ma una
cosa che potenzia gli altri quando è
fatta sinceramente quando diamo fiducia
sincera le altre persone le altre
persone sono molto più responsabili sono
molto più in empatia in sintonia con noi
e con quello che gli stiamo chiedendo
quello che stiamo chiedendo loro
e allora adesso che abbiamo imparato
seppur in breve tempo affidarci degli
altri proviamo anche a fidarci di noi
stessi
tante volte facciamo fatica a fidarci di
noi ci facciamo condizionare ci facciamo
ci facciamo influenzare dall'esterno
invece io vi invito veramente a
riflettere su questa cosa e vi racconto
un piccolo aneddoto che mi è successo
perché quando ho deciso di fare il
fisioterapista sono andato in
un'università e mi hanno consigliato
avevo chiesto ho detto appunto avrei
voluto fare fisioterapia e la persona
che ha accolto la mia richiesta matt
howard fisioterapia per chi per chi non
vede per chi non ha la vista è
complicata perché devi stare attento al
movimento dei pazienti devi abbiamo
degli esami a video insomma se vuoi fi
psicologia ma fisioterapia
lascia perdere io oggi ho deciso di
fidarmi di me stesso di quello che sono
delle mie consapevolezze e quindi o
bussata un'altra porta nella quale alla
quale ho trovato una risposta positiva
sono stato veramente accolto e sono
diventato poi strada facendo un
fisioterapista pensate però a quanto
sarebbe potuta cambiare la mia vita
se mi fossi fidato cioè se non mi fossi
fidato di me stesso se non mi fossi se
daniele non avesse parlato con l'altra
parte di daniele e si fossero detti
vicendevolmente
mi fido mi fido una parte dell'altra mi
fido di te di quello che credi non avrò
mai una controprova non sa o non saprò
mai se questo tipo di cambiamento
sarebbe stato cioè fare lo psicologo per
intenderci sarebbe stato meglio peggio
quello che posso dire che non sarebbe
stato quello che in quel momento volevo
è la mia vita sarebbe stata
completamente differente e quindi è
bellissimo pensare che la fiducia ci
permette di esprimerci esprimere quello
che siamo
permette di esprimere le persone a cui
doniamo fiducia permette che si
esprimano fa sì che si esprimano senza
la paura magari del giudizio o del
pregiudizio perché quando hai fiducia ti
senti più forte
ti senti molto più forte e ti senti
proiettato verso quello che vuoi fare
non hai paura di quello che non dovresti
fare o che non può e non deve succedere
e allo stesso tempo fidarci di noi
stessi è proprio il compimento se
vogliamo più profondo e più ampio di
quella che è la fiducia perché stiamo
riponendo in noi stessi la nostra
fiducia e quindi saremo orientati verso
quello che vogliamo più che allontanati
da ciò che non vogliamo da ciò che
neghiamo da ciò che rifiutiamo e io l'ho
dovuto fare per professione appunto
perché nella mia vita la fiducia ha
rappresentato e rappresenta e
rappresenterà sicuramente un pilastro
importante consapevole del fatto che
fidarsi in modo sincero funziona quindi
veramente avere fiducia nelle persone
perché possano arricchire la nostra vita
e la nostra esistenza funziona allora
spero di potere insomma potervi lasciare
questo questo pensiero che mi sta molto
a cuore è sospeso
diciamo una vita senza vedere per
rendermene conto e lo condivido con voi
su su quanto su come attraverso la
fiducia si possono osservare le persone
perché tante volte soprattutto nelle
scuole quando vado a parlare quei
bambini che sono quelli che non si fanno
scrupoli nel fare le domande e mi
chiedono ma tu che non vedi la faccia di
tua mamma tu che non vedi il viso dei
tuoi genitori non sai come è fatto un
viso come fatta una persona questa cosa
non ti manca non ti genera dolore e
quindi a loro dico come dico adesso voi
che fidarsi di una persona è un modo per
vederla in profondità avere fiducia in
un altra persona avere fiducia negli
altri
è un bellissimo modo per vederli con
altri occhi che sono probabilmente gli
occhi del cuore
[Applauso]
no voglio far dire di gianni mansi
allora
qui ho fatto bene a fidarmi perché siete
ancora qui nessuno è andato via
e siccome voglio fidarmi per l'ultima
volta
quantomeno per adesso di voi vi invito
ad alzarmi in piedi lo avete fatto
abbracciate la persona che avete vicino
e dite vi null'altro da oggi mi fiderò
più di me stesso e degli altri
grazie mille mi fiderò più di me stesso
e degli altri
[Applauso]
insomma